c'est l'heure du journal de l'Afrique ça
il est bienvenu sur France 24 à la une
ce soir c'est violent combat dans l'est
de la République démocratique du Congo
l'armée régulière et les rebelle du M23
s'affrontent à l'arme lourde les combats
sont intenses à quibomba et dans le
territoire du nirabongo c'est dans ce
contexte que l'ancien président kenyan
ou kenyata s'est rendu à Kinshasa pour
tenter de mener une médiation mais pour
parler de paix doivent débuter le 21
novembre au Kenya
l'espoir de voir l'aide humanitaire
parvenir en fin dans la région du Tigré
en Éthiopie 12 jours après la signature
d'un Cécile feu entre le front de
libération du peuple du Tigre et le
gouvernement fédéral la population
attend toujours les détails dans un
instant et puis cette bonne nouvelle
pour les consommateurs dans la région de
Dakar au Sénégal la baisse des prix
annoncée par le président Macky Sall
contre la vie chère est entré en vigueur
ce samedi les autorités sénégalaises qui
demandent par ailleurs aux commerçants
de s'aligner sur les prix fixés vous
verrez que ces derniers ne sont pas
contents reportage de nos équipes à
Dakar
c'est violent combat entre l'armée
congolaise et les rebelles du M23 des
combats à l'arme lourdes à une vingtaine
de kilomètres au nord de Goma dans l'est
de la République démocratique du Congo
selon des sources militaires il se
poursuivent à Kimba dans le territoire
du niragongo et dans le même temps
l'ancien président kenyan ou Kenya
médiateur dans cette crise est à
Kinshasa des pourparler de paix sur la
situation dans l'est du pays doivent
débuter le 21 novembre au Kenya écoutez
au Kenyatta
depuis 30 ans
les populations de l'Est de la RDC et
les congolais dans leur ensemble sont
empêchés de vivre normalement à cause
des violences et de l'instabilité
ceci est causé par de multiples groupes
armés actifs depuis trop longtemps
il est donc important que nous les
Africains de l'Est
travaillant ensemble pour établir une
paix durable afin que nos peuples
puissent commercer et circuler librement
le but est que nous soyons une vraie
communauté
qui ne soit pas anéanti par la guerre
externe ainsi le président Tshisekedi
dans la main
à tous les groupes armés qui veulent
bien baisser les armes et qui veulent
bien venir à la table des négociations
tout comme
après la signature d'un cessez-le-feu
entre les rebelles du Tigre et le
gouvernement fédéral Ethiopien il y a 12
jours n'est toujours pas parvenu dans la
région du Tigré la population a été
durement touchée par le conflit et
souffre de la famine les organisations
internationales se préparent en
attendant d'avoir le feu vert et de
pouvoir se rendre sur place les
précisions de notre correspondant dans
la région Bastien renouy la
l'humanitaire n'arrive pas encore
retirer mais cela pourrait bientôt être
le cas c'est ce que me disent des
employés des Nations Unies basées à
Addis-Abeba selon eux il y a des
discussions en cours entre le
gouvernement éthiopien les agences ou
louisiennes et le front de libération du
peuple du Tigré pour discuter et bien
des modalités du déploiement de cette
aide humanitaire toujours selon ses
employés une partie de l'aide est déjà
prédisposée à proximité du Tigré pour
pouvoir être sur place en moins de 48
heures quand le feu vert leur sera donné
7 heures d'humanitaire contient
principalement de la nourriture mais
aussi de quoi apporter les premiers
soins à la population une population qui
en a vraiment besoin plus de 90% de la
population a besoin d'aide humanitaire
alors il y a des négociations qui ont
continué durant toute la semaine
dernière entre le TPLF et le
gouvernement éthiopien des discussions
qui embouties à la signature d'un
document ce samedi qui donne et bien une
marche à suivre pour parvenir à la paix
dans ce document il y a aussi l'aide
humanitaire qui a été abordé notamment
la mise en place de points de contrôle
par le gouvernement éthiopien et ce afin
de contrôler qu'il s'agisse bien d'aide
destinée aussi ville le gouvernement
éthiopien qui explique d'ailleurs avoir
déjà apporté de l'aide sur place sans
donner beaucoup plus de détails sans
dire ou exactement et si la population
on a réellement bénéficié de dire qu'ils
sont contredis par le fond de libération
du peuple du tigre qui affirme qu'il n'y
a absolument pour l'instant aucune aide
humanitaire présente au tigré et qu'au
contraire et bien le gouvernement
continue à s'en prendre aux civil et à
bombarder certaines régions
on ne peut pas plaire à tout le monde au
Sénégal les consommateurs se sont
soulagés la baisse des prix annoncés par
le président Macky Sall contre la vie
chère est entrée en vigueur ce samedi
dans la région de Dakar mais l'État qui
subventionne les produits de première
nécessité pour lutter contre l'inflation
exige désormais des commerçants qu'il
s'aligne sur les prix fixés ces derniers
ne cachent pas leur mécontentement
reportage à Dakar de Sarah Sako et
limendao
marcher de face en plein cœur de Dakar
annoncé il y a une semaine les nouveaux
prix sont en vigueur depuis ce week-end
l'oignon la pomme de terre les œufs les
huiles le sucre ou encore le riz sont
concernés le kilo de la céréale à la
base de l'alimentation des Sénégalais
est ainsi passé de 350 à 325 francs
cfaante de cette baisse parce que tout
était cher
le riz est cher surtout au détail on est
vraiment très fatigué
le ministère du Commerce procède à des
contrôles sur le terrain plusieurs
saisies ont eu lieu ce lundi une
opération qui durera un mois selon ses
agents
l'affiche avec les nouveaux prix pour
les consommateurs elle est où
ce commerçant n'applique pas les
nouvelles mesures il est aussitôt
verbalisé
par rapport à la législation
le détaillant de son côté estime la
mesure injuste
il se réveille un beau matin avec leur
nouveau prix et ils veulent qu'on les
applique tout de suite sans nous laisser
le temps d'écouler nos stocks
autre mesure annoncées particulièrement
attendue des populations la baisse des
loyers se inférieur à 300.000 francs Cfa
un peu plus de 450 euros et qui concerne
la grande majorité des habitants devrait
par exemple baisser de 20%
. direction la Côte d'Ivoire le pays
ambitionne de devenir le hub énergétique
d'Afrique de l'Ouest avec un projet la
plus grande centrale à biomasse de la
région elle devrait être opérationnelle
dans deux ans elle produira de
l'électricité pour des milliers de
personnes le gouvernement ivoirien à
l'aide de près et de fonds
internationaux mis sur des projets
d'énergie renouvelables avec pour
objectif de réduire ses émissions de gaz
à effet de serre de 30 à 50% d'ici 2030
reportage de Sophie Lamothe et
sadiamundjo
des résidus de feuilles de palmier pour
créer de l'électricité en Côte d'Ivoire
c'est la promesse de la future centrale
à biomasse en construction ici à
boisseau dans le sud-est du pays prévu
pour 2024 la centrale la plus grande
d'Afrique de l'Ouest permettra de brûler
500 mille tonnes de déchets de palmier
la combustion créera de la vapeur d'eau
qui produira ensuite de l'électricité
industrie existante déjà en Côte
d'Ivoire et qui est en plus disponible
en grande abondance dans ce pays qui
permet de produire à peu près 350 gigawh
par an d'électricité
ça parle peu mais quand on le traduit en
nombre de personnes que ça permet
d'alimenter c'est 1,7 millions de
personnes que l'on peut alimenter en
électricité grâce à cette centrale
des arguments qui séduisent les
investisseurs sur le climat notamment au
sein de l'Union européenne le projet est
une vitrine ici à Côte d'Ivoire le
potentiel pour le transition énergétique
on peut regarder on peut regarder
d'abord le possibilité de investir dans
le énergie renouvelable il y a une
énorme potentielle il y a aussi une
énorme potentielle de saisir tous les
opportunités pour être plus efficaces en
termes de consommation d'énergie l'État
ivoirien veut porter à 42% la part des
énergies renouvelables dans son mix
énergétique qui est composé pour
l'instant majoritairement d'énergie
thermique pour cette expert en énergie
ce défi et déjà en face d'être relevé la
Côte d'Ivoire est déjà dans la
transition énergétique parce qu'il
s'agit d'une transition et les objectifs
aujourd'hui c'est d'être au-delà de
d'une cinquantaine de pour cent en ce
qui concerne la production d'énergie
renouvelable d'ici 2030 la Côte d'Ivoire
produit majoritairement de l'énergie
thermique et hydraulique qu'elle revend
au pays frontaliers si cette transition
énergétique aboutit le pays pourrait
alors devenir le hub énergétique de
toute l'Afrique de l'Ouest
j-6 avant le coup d'envoi de la Coupe du
monde de football au Qatar un événement
très attendu sur le continent au Kenya
les fans de football n'ont pas
l'intention de rater un match surtout
ceux des équipes africaines qu'ils
espèrent voir aller le plus loin
possible Caroline Lamboley
le Kenya ne s'est jamais qualifié pour
un mondial mais peu importe pour ses
fans de foot dans la capitale Nairobi
ils attendent impatiemment le début de
la compétition et espère voir une équipe
africaine remportait la coupe
le Mondial c'est vraiment un immense
évènement c'est une bonne chose pour
l'Afrique qui est pour le monde entier
on attend les matchs avec grande
impatience ça arrive une fois tous les
quatre ans et ça nous donne
l'opportunité de voir les grands joueurs
le Kenya ne participera pas mais on a
hâte de voir jouer le Sénégal le Maroc
la Tunisie le Ghana le Cameroun on
espère qu'un pays africain va bien s'en
tirer mais finalement ce qui rend les
coupes du monde si spécial c'est
l'excitation l'attente les supporters
des écrans ont été installés partout
dans le pays certains supporters mise
sur le Ghana d'autres sur le Sénégal
actuel champion du continent je trouve
qu'au sein de l'équipe du Sénégal il y a
une très bonne el chimie déjà ce sont
eux les champions d'Afrique ils ont un
bon gardien de but une bonne défense un
bon milieu de terrain une bonne attaque
donc parmi les pays africains je pense
que ce sont eux qui iront le plus loin
l'équipe sénégalaise est arrivée au
Qatar lundi matin aux aurores avec un
grand absent Sadio Manet
vendredi le sélectionneur Aliou Cissé
s'est dit vraiment optimiste espérant
que le deuxième au classement du Ballon
d'Or pourra se remettre à temps de sa
blessure pour participer au tournoi
et nous aussi dans le journal de la Free
qu'on suivra à l'évolution de ses
équipes africaines c'est la fin de cette
édition merci aux équipes en régime
merci à nos correspondances en qui ce
journal n'existerait pas merci à notre
chef d'édition Celia caracena et merci
pour votre fidélité restez avec nous
l'info continue sur France 24
[Musique]